but first over the past 18 months you
might have noticed that joe biden and
the climate cult alarmists who control
him
sometimes pretend that they think they
have a monopoly of compassion they feel
your pain
in reality they want you to feel pain
they want it joe promised it he's
delivering they want you to pay more at
the pump they want your energy bills to
be higher they want food prices to rise
they want you to make do with less all
in the name of climate change now
according to them the administration
must take extreme measures right now in
order to save mother earth from imminent
doom now ultimately this is nothing more
than window dressing in other words a
huge trojan horse for big government
socialism they want to fundamentally
transform this country even if it means
your life gets a hell of a lot worse now
the climate cult alarmists are waging a
war on the american people on our
budgets they are disproportionately
impacting negatively the poor the middle
class people on fixed income the elderly
in this country but don't take my word
for it listen to small town mayor and
genius the man of all experience
transportation secretary pete buddha
judge mayor pete look
the higher the gap the price of gas than
the the faster you reach that parity of
course the more pain we are all
experiencing from the high price price
of gas the more benefit there is for
those who can access electric vehicles
it's why we're hoping you and your
colleagues might reconsider opposing the
reduction of ev upfront prices with tax
credits so so you you're saying the more
pain we have the more benefit we're
going to get of course i think that's
what i heard you say
the more pain that's that's what you're
hearing that's what i heard you say i
know you want me to say it so bad
he swear did you get that the more pain
you experience the more benefit for
electric vehicles now maybe you didn't
quite hear it i think it's worth playing
one more time pay very close attention
and keep in mind joe biden promised
during the campaign he would eliminate
fossil fuels i guess with the exception
didn't tell us about the exception for
russia iran venezuela opec and saudi
arabia but he said he'd eliminate them
take a look again the more pain we are
all experiencing from the high price
price of gas the more benefit there is
for those who can access electric
vehicles
the more pain the more benefit uh your
pain is a good thing uh not for you of
course but for our great transition and
those that can afford it now keep in
mind an average electric vehicle in case
you don't know is over 20 grand more
than a gas powered car so you're paying
a lot more up front uh of course aside
from filling in potholes in south bend
indiana biden's brilliant transportation
secretary doesn't really have much
experience in transportation at all but
remember mayor pete wasn't appointed to
make our roads and bridges and airports
safer and more efficient now he's in
office to help foster a fundamental
transition to this green new deal
socialist utopia of an economy which we
now know is a disaster which in the end
isn't green at all electric cars for
example they're not telling you this
part they don't actually improve the
environment according to a recent study
the brand new hummer electric vehicle
actually produces more carbon emissions
than a gas-powered chevy malibu hmm why
is that well first the battery on an
electric vehicle is typically comprised
of nickel cobalt aluminum and manganese
all of which need to be mined from
mother earth with heavy equipment that
uses diesel second that battery
constantly needs to be plugged in and
recharged look at that chart right there
where do we get our energy from where's
electricity come from i bet we don't
have we don't think about it often
eighty percent of the power that you use
to recharge these electric vehicles
comes from oil gas and coal now because
of the extreme cost to build and operate
along with a very small
energy output wind solar and all other
forms of so-called renewable energy they
only make up about 12 percent of our
power grid and they're very unreliable
ask texas for this foreseeable future a
major transition to renewables even in
the near future in the next 10 15 20
years is likely totally impossible so in
order to maintain the green energy front
to this quote economic transition in
other words the pain that you're going
to be uh pay for and the pain that's
going to cause you and your family biden
is restricting american domestic fossil
fuel production and refinery capacity
while attempting to make up the deficit
by importing more oil more gas the
lifeblood of our economy from overseas
now the result an economy and an
environment that is suffering oiling gas
is more expensive and guess what when
you import it if it's imported from
countries with lacks environmental
regulations and then shipped in massive
gas powered vessels across the ocean the
climate cult needs to answer one simple
question i wish somebody would ask joe
biden or kamala harris please ask this
question
why is it okay to beg russia import from
russia import from iran beg venezuela
beg the the saudi pariah nation of saudi
arabia
beg the killer of jamal khashoggi
according to joe biden why is it okay to
beg opec for hundreds and hundreds of
millions of barrels of oil that they
will give to us sell to us at a high
rate and get them rich when we can
produce all of it here we do it faster
we do it cheaper and guess what we do it
cleaner explain all of this insanity to
the american people because they have a
right to know at this point paying
record high gas prices and a 41 year
high of inflation but again the left's
climate hysteria it's really not about
the environment is it they told us in
the beginning green new deal guaranteed
government health care government
guaranteed wage guaranteed job
guaranteed college guaranteed government
healthy food guaranteed retirement it's
about a transition to socialism take a
look
what is the short term in the medium
term so that we can make sure we have
enough oil and gas to support us through
the transition and what are the kind of
steps that we don't want the oil and gas
industry to take that would have
long-term consequences when we don't
want
new major projects that would take 20 30
years to to become profitable so we have
to make that differentiation to make
sure that the american consumer has what
it needs to grow to grow our economy and
the global economy but not take steps
and endanger the climate uh
work that we're trying to do to make
sure that we're on a better footing to
accelerate the transition are you
listening the transition that you're a
part of that you're paying for that
advisor is not the only biden official
talking about an accelerated transition
take a look for yourself the
challenge for all of us now is that no
one country can solve this problem by
itself
we all have to be able to reduce the
emissions we have to accelerate the
transition we're behind
we're not yet
fulfilling the promises that we made in
glasgow
so we have our work cut out for us
more pain more progress we have our work
cut out for us word of the day
transition transition when someone tells
you that they're going to do something
like joe biden said i'm going to
eliminate it i'm going to get rid of
fossil fuels next time you need to
believe them even better actions usually
speak louder than words now if it's the
ice caps they're claiming or melting and
the sea levels are rising at an
unsustainable level uh
why did obama and biden both of them
just shell out millions and millions of
dollars for beachfront homes now if the
planet is now facing imminent
destruction then why does biden special
envoy for the climate
john i voted for the 87 billion before i
voted against kerry why does he own and
operate a massive private jet i don't
care that he has one but he's a
hypocrite kerry's gulfstream made 48
trips since biden took office emitting
over 300 metric tons of carbon that's
more than you'll probably use in a
lifetime now if this truly is a crisis
why isn't john leading by example giving
up his private jet maybe he can sell him
on the free market and get good deals
for other people but don't worry in his
upcoming international trip for the
white house on climate a kerry
spokesperson is telling foxnews.com that
the climate czar might actually fly in a
government jet instead that's right in
the midst of the so-called climate
crisis our federal government your
government that's putting all this pain
on you and your families they continue
to own and operate a massive fleet of
passenger jets that they use to ferry
around all these cabinet and government
officials and other government vips all
told your federal government they own a
whopping 924
aircraft across 11 agencies 500 planes
most of them jets over 400 helicopters
now think about it your federal
government is asking you to drive less
fly less eat less suffer in silence pay
astronomical
rates for a gallon of gasoline one
record high after another all because of
the urgent climate emergency and the
need to transition and they jet all over
the world in a massive fleet of
government aircraft that you pay for and
you pay for the jet fuel as well which
of course leaves a huge carbon footprint
that they say that they're against that
they don't even want out of your suv and
they want you to buy
an electric vehicle that you can't
afford and by the way costs four times
the amount of gasoline are you paying
now we're talking about more than 600
million dollars for government aircraft
every single year for their private jets
for their helicopters you buy them you
pay for them they fly in them but then
they lecture you let me state the
obvious climate change is not a national
emergency it is not a crisis we're not
facing imminent doom or extinction they
don't have anything to transition to
and thank god because the federal
government is not doing anything to
improve the environment by the way
donald trump made us energy independent
and oh guess what out of the
industrialized world we reduce carbon
emissions more than anybody the real
danger here is the left's attempt to
grab power with the hope of transforming
our economy into their top down
government government-controlled social
socialist hellhole so when someone tells
you the sky is falling and we have just
12 years to save mother earth but they
won't produce energy here domestically
but they'll take it from the russians
and the iranians and the venezuelans and
the saudis and opec just know they're
either delusional or they have ulterior
motives hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else